[Música]
Donald Trump vuelve al banquillo de los
acusados el ex mandatario comparecerá
Este martes ante un tribunal Federal por
el mal manejo de los documentos
clasificados hallados en su mansión en
Florida tras dejar la Casa Blanca
tenemos informe desde Miami
a un año de las elecciones
presidenciales en México ya hay tres
candidatos que quieran aspirar por el
partido oficialista Morena al canciller
Marcelo ebrardt se suman la jefa de
gobierno de Ciudad de México Claudia
sheinbaum y el senador Ricardo Monreal
la Unión Europea podría sellar su
acuerdo comercial con mercosur para
final de año la jefe de la comisión
europea Úrsula Thunder Legend se mostró
optimista al respecto durante un
encuentro con el presidente brasileño
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva en Brasilia
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Estados Unidos Este martes el
expresidente Donald Trump está citado a
comparecer ante un tribunal en la en
Florida donde se le imputarán 37 cargos
federales por el mal manejo de
documentos clasificados que fueron
encontrados en su mansión de mar a lago
las autoridades locales se preparan para
posibles disturbios ante la presencia de
varios grupos de Seguidores del Magnate
republicano los detalles con nuestro
corresponsal alto nivelci Sí de hecho
las autoridades del sur de la Florida
han preparado un dispositivo especial de
seguridad más de 1400 agentes van a
estar desplegados por las inmediaciones
de esta corte Federal en colaboración
también con los agentes federales lo que
quieren evitar es que hayan disturbios
porque se espera que hayan
manifestaciones dice la policía de 5000
a 50.000 personas por eso no quieren
dejar nada al azar y que y mantener Todo
bajo control también sea acordonado ya
todo el acceso a esta corte Federal
precisamente para evitar en la medida de
lo posible los disturbios desde la
ciudad de Miami informan que no hay
planificada ningún tipo de manifestación
a pesar de que alertan que a través de
las redes sociales se está haciendo un
llamado para la movilización
y en otras noticias de Estados Unidos
luego de que el pentágono desestimara la
información del periódico de Wall Street
journal que informaba sobre un presunto
acuerdo entre China y Cuba para instalar
una base de espionaje en la isla la Casa
Blanca dijo haber expresado al gobierno
cubano sus preocupaciones al respecto y
que aunque las relaciones con china son
tensas en este momento el presidente Joe
biden está comprometido a mantener
abiertas las líneas de comunicación
tanto Beijing como la Habana ha negado
tales afirmaciones
pasamos a México donde se agitó la
candidatura presidencial dentro del
partido oficialista Morena para las
elecciones de 2024 este lunes el
canciller Marcelo ebrard dejó su puesto
para comenzar la campaña por otro lado
también se lanzaron la jefa de gobierno
de Ciudad de México Claudia sheinbaum
quien encabeza las primeras encuestas y
el líder oficialista del senado Ricardo
Monreal morena anunciará a su candidato
el 6 de septiembre Ramiro cueva barrena
nos cuenta más
Aún falta un año para las elecciones
pero la carrera para suceder a Andrés
Manuel López Obrador en la presidencia
mexicana empieza a tomar forma hoy estoy
presentando mi renuncia porque estamos
resuelto a participar el día de ayer
estuvimos en el Consejo Nacional Aquí no
hay planes de El plan a es ganar y
vencer a la anuncio del canciller
Marcelo ebrard se sumó la alcaldesa de
Ciudad de México Claudia sheinbaum que
lidera las primeras encuestas
que he tomado la decisión
de separarme del cargo de forma
definitiva el 16 de junio del presente
con el fin de llegar a ser la primera
mujer en la historia de México
el encabezar los destinos de la
naturaleza
junto a Brad y sheinbaum también
competirán el líder oficialista en el
senado Ricardo Monreal quien anunció que
dejará el cargo el próximo viernes y el
ministro del interior Adán Augusto López
que todavía debe oficializar su salida
morena pautó reglas claras para todos
los precandidatos para competir en la
interna tienen que dejar sus puestos en
el estado esta semana y la disputa
deberá ser Leal No puede haber
denostación entre compañeros tiene que
haber absoluto respeto y tampoco pueden
pues hablar mal o desacreditar a este
proceso porque tiene todo el consenso
del Consejo Nacional a la lista de
contendientes pueden sumarse al senador
Manuel Velasco y Gerardo Fernández
Noroña si el partido verde y los
laboristas lo aprueban morena que para
las generales de 2024 acordó que el 6 de
septiembre se anunciará el ganador tras
el proceso de selección la presidenta de
la comisión europea Úrsula fonder Legend
estuvo en Brasil como parte de su gira
por América Latina en una reunión con el
presidente Luis Ignacio lulada Silva
abordaron temas como el acuerdo
comercial entre el mercosur y la Unión
Europea y la deforestación de la
amazonía marina sardinha tiene los
detalles
su primera parada en su gira
latinoamericana la presidenta de la
comisión europea Úrsula ponder Legend se
reunió en Brasilia con el presidente
brasileño Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva y
anunció la entrega de unos 20 millones
de dólares para la protección de la
selva amazónica a través del fondo
amazonía creado en 2008 pero suspendido
en 2019 durante el gobierno de la
expresidente ultraderechista Jair
bolsonaro
hablamos de la selva amazónica la selva
amazónica es una maravilla de la
naturaleza es el pulmón verde de nuestro
planeta y es un Aliado clave contra el
calentamiento global
en las conversaciones también se habló
de desbloquear el acuerdo de libre
comercio entre los cuatro países que
conforman el mercosur y la Unión Europea
que entraría en vigor a final de año si
los sudamericanos logran acordar una
postura conjunta antes de la próxima
Ronda de conversaciones
que no tiene de alguna forma nada que
pueda trabajar sobre las controversias
no es un sistema aduanero perfecto no es
un sistema migratorio tampoco perfecto
entre los cuatro países parecería muy
raro que una Unión muy perfecta como la
puede ser la Unión Europea encaje con
una Unión muy perfecta como lo que es el
mercosur no es culpa de la Unión Europea
en este caso es culpa de los cuatro
países latinoamericanos que no se han
puesto de acuerdo Pese a que la Unión
Europea es ya el mayor inversor en
América Latina el bloque europeo pone el
énfasis en la protección medioambiental
como principal compromiso para cerrar el
pacto comercial por su parte Lula
criticó las estrictas condiciones y
aseguró temer las sanciones
medioambientales
la premisa que debe existir entre socios
estratégicos es la de confianza mutua no
la desconfianza y las sanciones
esto llega en un momento crítico para la
amazonía la deforestación en Brasil
aumentó un 22,3% respecto al año
anterior el equivalente al territorio de
un país como Israel
la justicia Argentina envió a juicio
oral a los tres imputados por el
atentado contra la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández El pasado mes de
septiembre la decisión de la jueza
encargada del caso se da en línea con el
fiscal quien había solicitado cerrar la
investigación y elevarla a juicio oral
Fernández ha criticado el proceso
insistiendo en que con él se ha evitado
conocer la verdad incluso señala
presuntos nexos del ataque con políticos
de la oposición
Estados Unidos decidió regresar a la
UNESCO luego de cinco años ausente desde
que el gobierno de Donald Trump anunció
la salida de su país en octubre de 2017
alegando un sesgo anti israelí
recriminando la postura sobre los
debates de los conflictos en medio
oriente china no se opone a su retorno y
la directora general celebró la medida
pero Washington deberá pagar más de 600
millones de dólares por los retrasos
uno deshace el otro repara las
diferencias entre ambos presidentes
vuelven a marcarse tras cinco años de
ausencia Estados Unidos quiere recuperar
su lugar en la UNESCO
deseo informarle En nombre del
departamento de estado que Estados
Unidos tiene el honor de proponerle un
plan para su regreso a la UNESCO según
la directora general
si a la UNESCO le va bien le irá a un
mejor con el regreso de Estados Unidos
la vocación del multilateralismo es
acoger a todas las naciones grandes y
pequeñas
esta decisión estadounidense se inscribe
en un contexto general de creciente
rivalidad entre Washington y Beijing y
la cuestión del regreso de Estados
Unidos a la UNESCO es un claro indicio
por eso china establece ciertas
condiciones
Esperamos que la UNESCO siga las normas
en este Estados Unidos a pagar Integra y
puntualmente sus atrasos
la suma deudada llega a casi 600
millones de dólares la ruptura la
provocó Donald Trump en octubre de 2017
el ex presidente estadounidense denunció
entre otras cosas el sesgo anti israelí
al mismo tiempo Israel abandonó la
UNESCO Estados Unidos se retiró por
primera vez en 1984 En aquel momento
Ronald Reagan denunció la inutilidad de
tal organización pero en 2003 Washington
hizo una reaparición bajo el gobierno
del presidente George Bush
hoy Esta reintegración debe someterse
primero al voto de otros 193 estados y
se necesita una mayoría la votación
tendrá lugar el próximo Julio sin
embargo en la UNESCO se considera poco
probable un rechazo hasta aquí es
informativo Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]